John why do you say that comedy is both
truth and pain comedy is truth and pain
because in every human moment if you are
aware of it you can detect an underlying
truth and pain of that moment a joke is
something that looks at and explores the
truth in pain and gives the audience an
opportunity to think about it in a
slightly different way here's a classic
a a fellow is falling from a skyscraper
and it gets down about the 33rd 34th
floor and some guy leans out the window
says how's it going it says okay so far
so the underlying truth in pain is
here's a guy who's in Peril that's the
truth and the pain is there's nothing he
can do about it and his expression
there's okay so far is an acknowledgment
of the truth and pain but indirectly and
if you look at any joke you can think of
you're going to find that it is an
indirect acknowledgment of Truth and
pain
by Nature then are funny people cruel
that's a great question
I like to say comedy is cruelty
a thing isn't funny to the person it's
happening to it's funny to the people
watching it's not necessary that
you don't have to be cruel to make
comedy but there is an element of
Cruelty in jokes because the thing isn't
funny to the person it's happening to we
derive our emotional sustenance from
experiencing vicariously the conflict or
predicament or Peril of somebody else
and being observing it
but far enough away from it that it's
not us that's what gives us the
emotional bond that makes us engage in
the emotional separation that makes us
laugh
further to that if I may
when people are creating characters in a
situation comedy or comic film for
example they often become caught up in
the in the the sense of I'm hurting
these characters I don't want to hurt my
characters
this is uh in a sense conflict avoidance
in real life walking around the world a
lot of us try to avoid conflict I do I
don't like conflict as a writer I don't
have to engage in it I can just go home
and write but when I am guiding
characters through story my emotional
need to protect them from conflict
fights against the need of the story
which is to put them under pressure so
they can advance toward a new
understanding of themselves
characters and stories like people in
the real world will not undergo
authentic change unless they're forced
to they'll stay in a status quo all
stories in a sense put pressure and
increasingly more and more pressure on a
character until the character is forced
to enter an explosive new truth the
consequence of this is in order to help
our characters achieve their growth we
have to burden them with opposition with
conflict so the thing that we're afraid
of giving them conflict that's actually
the thing they need
can you explain how comedy begins with
someone's suffering
the classic comic book comic uh moment
we can think of is somebody slipping on
a banana peel if you're a five-year-old
you're laughing at that why are you
laughing at that somebody slipped on a
banana peel they might have gotten hurt
but if you look at the person who slips
on the banana peel it's never an
innocent person it's always somebody who
in some sense deserves it somebody who
is the wrong attitude arrogant
selfishness uh uh impatience
uh clumsiness that's not exactly On
Target but
if a person with high status slips on a
banana peel then the person with eye
status is brought low
and the the fall from high status to low
status for people who have low status is
always very funny and for most people in
audience situations low status is kind
of baked in they're in the audience
they're not their performers so if they
see the high and mighty performers slip
and fall or otherwise suffer
they get the first benefit of watching a
funny thing happen to someone who's not
them the second benefit of seeing
somebody
some high and mighty person brought low
and then the third benefit of processing
all of this more information more
effectively because they have a new way
to think about it and experience it that
guy was rushing he slipped on a banana
peel fell on his butt and I laughed but
I also learned a lesson and the lesson
is don't rush and also don't be so high
and mighty so there's a lot packed into
a joke that looks like it's about the
suffering but it's really about
triggering the laugh reflex which is a
matter of giving the audience a puzzle
to solve and then letting them solve it
what's going on here how is slipping on
a banana field and appeal impacting the
situation what's the new result aha
guy with status slipped on a banana peel
I'm laughing
so let's say if I'm at an office party
the office Christmas party and my good
friend comes from the bathroom she has
lipstick on her teeth or forbid she has
a pantyhose tucked in the back I'm going
to tell her but if it's Marge from
accounting who I can't stand and who's
who's who's messed with my check I might
I might laugh at that I think I think
that's a great example because a thing
is important funny to the person that's
happening to and that includes close
allies
like if it's happening to me I feel it
if it's happening to people I care about
I feel it in a different way than if
it's happening to people I don't care
about or hate through the example that
that you suggested I'm going to help my
friend because this isn't a laughing
situation I I have no vow I get no value
out of making fun of my friends although
some people do
but I do get value out of making fun of
Marge from accounting who is deserving
what she's getting at this moment I'm
reminded of something that my wife and I
passed through early in our relationship
being a funny guy I would make jokes
about anything and everything and some
of those jokes were kind of at her
expense
you know like my wife she doesn't know
how she
says she's so dumb she couldn't pass a
blood test
as an example of a joke that doesn't do
me or my relationship or my wife or our
relationship any good at all over time I
learned that if I'm telling a joke at
the expense of a loved one I'm doing
damage that I don't want to do and don't
need to do
you can consider stand-up comic having
the challenge
how can I be on stage and talk about my
family in a way that's funny
and in a way that gets the laughs and
advances my career the way I suppose the
way I wanted to and speaks the truth
that I want to speak without hurting the
people around me
it's possible but it's it's a space that
needs investigating
but on the flip side we can we can tear
ourselves apart and it's actually funny
and and in that you find the solution to
the problem how do I make fun of my
family without
hurting my family I make fun of myself
I don't say my family is so stupid they
do X Y or Z I say I'm so stupid I don't
understand why my family does X Y or Z
and that gets you out of the Trap I can
give you a great example of this and
it's one that well we can reference
because it's in the public domain or in
the public sphere one would say years
ago I was in Russia running the Russian
version of Married With Children like
you do and I happen to be there at the
same time that Phil ramuno the creator
of Everybody Loves Raymond was in Russia
doing the pilot of Everybody Loves
Raymond for Russian television and also
doing a documentary of his own
experience now I was a fly on the wall
and I saw how my Russian colleagues
wanted to close off to him they were
afraid of him they were afraid that his
documentary would make fun of them that
the whole point of the exercise was to
mock the quaint and idiotic ways of the
Russian people but Phil romino is much
smarter than that the whole comic
perspective of the piece is there are
things going around here that I do not
understand and all the comic energy is
directed on what filter immuno does not
understand not directed at the things
he's observing and would otherwise be
tempted to make direct fun of
and as a consequence the documentary
works for American audiences and Russian
audiences because there's a
generosity of spirit underneath the
whole thing it's the filmmaker's
intention for everybody to have a good
time the Russians who are participating
in the documentary the audience watching
at home and he realizes his intention by
focusing all the comic energy on himself
which is a hundred percent safe Target
all the time
as a coded to that story if you happen
to watch that video watch very closely
at the end there's a wrap party for the
documentary and the pilot and I'm in the
background and you can see me for that
long great so before we leave Russia if
I may yeah okay sort of ask and answer
my own question
we're interested in the question of
where do jokes come from what are they
made of how do they work and we've
addressed one thing that's for sure
comedy is truth and pain comedy is
cruelty but here's something else to
look at and it's called defeat of
expectation I'll tell you a joke and
then we'll deconstruct it a little bit
this joke comes to mind because it's
about Russian vodka I was in Russia and
I was given some Russian pepper vodka to
try well pepper vodka very hot and I
tasted it and they asked me how was it I
said well it starts like Tabasco and
finishes like paint thinner
so now the defeat of expectation is
found in the phrase and finishes like
paint thinner because the way I have set
the joke up I'm describing the Vodka as
if I were an expert like a wine expert
it starts you know it starts with notes
of cherry and finishes with oak or
something like that you and the audience
are already putting the pieces of the
puzzle together you're thinking oh he
sounds like a wine connoisseur he's
identified a note in the Vodka that I
would expect to find in a pepper vodka
at this point the audience doesn't
really know where the joke is going they
can expect that it's not going to go to
it starts like Tabasco and finishes like
Frank's Louisiana hot sauce because
there's no surprise there there's
nothing interesting there but if I say
starts like Tabasco and finishes like
paint thinner I have created a picture
in the mind of something that's ah
horrible and completely destroyed the
picture in the mind of something that's
being apprehended like a glass of fine
wine and that destruction of one image
and it's instantaneous replacement with
another that's a comic tool called
defeat of expectation